so you've told the telegraph you're
going to be striking from the north of
scotland down to the tip of cornwall why
do you want to see strike action
we don't want strike action this is a
defensive action against the companies
and the government in fact who are
bringing in stringent cuts thousands of
jobs of our members some thousands have
already gone
and there are thousands more to go
they also want to completely change the
conditions that our members have agreed
with their employers
and we haven't had a pay rise for a very
long time many of our members are now in
the third anniversary of not having a
pay rise they worked all the way through
covid
they mainly had to work
at work not staying at home working
online
and they're fed up with it they want to
have job security they want to provide a
service for the public but we do need a
pay rise to keep up with the rocket and
inflation that we're all experiencing
you say that you need a pay rise and the
average uk salary is 31 000 pounds the
average railway salary is 45 000 pounds
that's not correct what's the correct
number the median salary for a railway
worker that we represent is 31 000
pounds it's exactly an over the average
um so
given the fact that you know it is in
line with the average and why some
people you know look at watching and
listening to this we'll be wondering why
it is that you do deserve a pay rise
ahead of others well all british workers
deserve a pay rise there's a bit of a
nonsense that goes around especially in
the media that says
if we get a pay rise somehow
other workers won't get a pay rise or if
we don't get a pay rise it will be
transferred to nurses to other public
sector workers and people that are also
being exploited that just won't happen
if we don't get a pay rise the profits
of the companies will just go up and
what needs to happen in the uk
is that some of these profits need to be
reduced so that british workers can get
a pay rise every worker in this country
is struggling at the moment they can't
keep up with the utility prices they
can't keep up with their household bills
we need a pay rise but we also need job
security because there's a lot of
precarious work and vulnerable work at
the moment and that's got to end if
you're saying that everyone deserves a
pay rise you're not worried about the
impact that this could have on inflation
which is you know the very thing that
everyone's really concerned about you
know the bank of england governor andrew
bailey calling for pay restraint because
his pay restraint he's on 600 000 pounds
a year as is the chief of network rail
there are railway bosses taking home
millions of pounds every year the
railways made 500 million pound of
profit last year when uh fares and
passengers were at an all-time low
people are stripping money
out of the railway they're stripping
money out of the economy and if workers
wages don't go up it means a transfer of
wealth from the poor to the rich we've
got more billionaires than we've ever
had in this country the rich have never
been richer and the reason they're able
to do that and get richer all the time
is because they're deliberately
depressing workers wages inflation has
come on board now and virtually nobody's
had a pay rise for the last two or three
years so this idea that there's a wages
price spiral is nonsense i totally get
um
and i'm sure many of our viewers will
share you know your assessment of the
very very high wages particularly the
high wages of those people calling for
pay restraint
but doesn't change the facts though does
it that if if lots of people get pay
rises and it could lead to inflation
well inflation is already here and
nobody said more inflation well it could
lead to more inflation but what could
also stop inflation is that some of the
companies could restrain their profits
and return that money into lower prices
bp and shell on the others are making
record profits of billions of pounds
every quarter and everyone yearly they
don't got so much money they don't know
what to do with it one of the things
they could do is sacrifice those profits
never mind a windfall tax what about a
dividend that goes back to the people
that are consuming their their materials
but also we've got thousands and
thousands if not millions of people who
are struggling and while they're working
and having to take benefits that's an
outrage the reason they have to take
benefits is they're not being paid
enough
and they need to be paid more okay
now just talking about the strike action
do you think it's now inevitable
well we're talking to the companies
we're talking to the companies at a very
senior level but they are taking a very
hard line they want to impose these cuts
while they're imposing record increases
and fares
their uh fare increases are linked to
the retail price index
wages on the question is do you think
the strikes are inevitable i can't see a
way out from the strikes at the moment
unless there's a breakthrough unless the
government instructs these companies
which they are doing to to change their
line rather than harden their line it's
very very likely that they'll be strike
action and it will be very soon and what
what level of pay increase would you
like to see for your members well i'll
negotiate that with the companies
there's a lot of ways to put value into
a package just give us a rough idea well
we want to see something that reflects
the ever-increasing costs our
anniversaries for these companies were
back in december and back in
april so does that mean you'd like to
see it roughly the same levels as
inflation well it needs to meet the
aspirations of our members which
coincide with inflation yes so roughly
around the level that inflation
currently is well that's what they need
to do to keep up otherwise our people
become poorer date to 10
well we'll talk to the companies about
that okay
now millions of people across the
country are gearing up to
make good use of the extra bank holidays
to celebrate the queen's
jubilee and and yet their plan strikes
on the london underground
well there's not we called off a strike
next friday we've got a way forward on
that which is on one of the public
holidays so there's no strike action by
the rmt over any of the queen's jubilee
celebrations on both the june the 3rd
and june the 6th well june 6 is after
the celebration okay but it's still on
the back holiday though isn't it well
the bank holds thursday and friday this
is a normal work day on the monday
okay right so you all right okay that's
where we are
you've you've you've caught off one of
the strike actions but how how worried
are you about the disruption that it
could cause people and the sympathy that
you might get well we don't want
disruption it's a hard road being a
trade unionist and taking industrial
action but we feel we have no choice the
london mayor is attacking our people
he's attacking their pensions he wants
to make them poorer permanently not just
while they're at work but while they're
in retirement it's exactly the same
agenda that the government's putting
forward through these funding
negotiations with the companies and with
the london mayor we cannot sit idly by
as a trade unionist while while our
people are being attacked
while they're at work while they finish
when they finish work for retirement and
very threat that they may lose their
jobs it's my job as a trade union leader
to defend our people and this is a
defensive strike if it happens their
tanks are on our lawn we're not
threatening them they're threatening our
people you're looking ahead to the
summer do you think we could see you
know a summer of discontent well there
are a lot of workers that are very upset
i'm seeing that there's action going on
in the local councils we've got refuse
workers we've got care workers
most people who come from traditional
working class environments find
themselves super exploited not only they
got poor wages they've got poor
conditions if they've got any conditions
but they also find themselves under the
threat of cuts and that being job cuts
so there has to be a response from all
of the trade unions and from the tuc and
we would like to see the labour party
and its leadership coming behind working
class people so that they ensure they
get a pay rise so there's some support
from the politicians as well as from the
trade unions and this this is a measure
for kia stammer so that he can decide
whether he's on the side of the workers
in this country or on the side of the
bosses do you think that he hasn't made
that clear then he hasn't made it clear
at all i've not heard him say once
uh during the current dispute such as at
the coventry uh
council where the labour council sought
to cut workers wages and cut their
conditions i've seen no response from
the labour front bench that says
we support the workers in their
struggles and that is the role of a
labour party
the name gives it away that there's a
put they're there to support the labour
movement do you think that kirsten was
on the side of workers i can't see you
at the moment
wow and so what do you think that means
for the you know the funding of the
labour party and the union support for
the load plan well my union's not
affiliated with the labour party but i
see many other unions general
secretaries and leaders thinking what is
the point of this connection if we just
get this bland democratic party sitting
in the center of
politics
taking their their instructions off the
daily mail to some extent and not
actually getting behind workers
struggles you have to ask yourself why
do they call themselves the labor party
so we need to see a strong line the
labour party needs to get back into
working class communities support better
wages and support the end of precarious
work which is outsourced subcontracted
and vulnerable work where you don't know
where you're going to get your next
week's work from in terms of these
flexible hours contracts and zero hours
contracts and all the rest of it so they
have to make a stand for working people
and i guess what kirsten would say is
that he's looked at the last uh election
results when there was a more left-wing
leader and it was a catastrophic set of
results for the labour party and that
it's hit up to him to try and re-engage
with some of those people who turned
away from labour yeah some of those
people have turned away from labour are
the people who have not got any decent
job security in this economy now if he
wants to go back to the red wall and now
the blue wall he's got to make a
connection with working people and one
of those things is about
the fact that there's no decent housing
being built by councils the fact that
people cannot rely on an income and the
fact that they're underpaid and this is
a crisis and it's time for kierstarma to
stand up for our people okay just uh
finally um you have previously said that
you can't rule out four-day uh strikes
are you concerned about what a four-day
strike could look like for this country
so you know for example you know if they
could lead to even the lights going out
because of disruption to services drax
power station north yorkshire servicing
millions of homes and there's only a
certain amount
of uh
of
power that it can stockpile are you
concerned i'm concerned about disruption
i don't want disruption and nor do my
members but they don't want to see their
conditions stripped out and they don't
want to live under an ever-present
threat of job cuts
network rail have already announced that
two and a half hours of my people will
be made redundant they've already made
1500 job cuts in that company and that's
the first installment now we're going to
see a stripped out dehumanized railway
if we're not careful if the companies
want to come back to the table and work
with us to get a proper settlement we
can do that very quickly and it wouldn't
need to be any strikes at all do you
think it genuinely could lead to the
lights going up i've got no idea it
depends how long the strike goes on if
there is strike action then it's up to
the government to give a mandate to the
companies that they can settle this
dispute how long could the strikes be
they could go on for a very very long
time because there's no sign at the
moment that anybody's backing down on
their side of the table
well we'll decide that as we go we want
to make the strike action if it happens
as effective as possible from our point
of view but just you are prepared to
strike for long enough that it could
affect the power supply if you don't get
you to have your demands matters our
members are prepared to take effective
strike action in pursuit of the
settlement of this dispute i've got no
idea how long that will take and i can't
determine from here what what the
outcomes and side effects of that will
be